guys before the video starts i'm doing
going to appeal for syria afghanistan
and ethiopia provinces inshallah people
are literally freezing we will never
live in those conditions help me reach
my target to give them some walls i've
done the seven day free trial of the
qurani app and it exceeded all my
expectations what was the system you can
build a habit with the quran buy seven
day free trial bonuses not credit card
details required at all and you decide
for yourself is it overrated or is it
underrated
assalamu alaikum whatever they better
care brothers and sisters and dear
friends before i start with a praise
allah the most most of the most trust or
praise his glory and gratitude belong to
him so i was sent this video uh
from it's it's the russell howard as you
guys know he's a comedian he's on this
show and he's been asking questions and
the presenter of the show asks him a
specific question why he prefers
to work at a different tv station rather
than bbc this is what he had to say
let's listen to it and um see what we
can take out of
i said the it
aren't muslims they're terrorists can
you say isis aren't fundamental muslims
they're terrorists you know what we're
going to get a letter from isis
okay guys so we saw that for ourselves
now it's very interesting because i was
discussing with brothers ishaan and a
few others is it worth doing and um
some of the brothers did say that
basically if you think about it like
what bbc are doing
is kind of right you know because they
do not want to
misrepresent let's say for example but
then again i was thinking to myself you
know the process of said every action is
based on its intention now it might be
like to me for example um it might seem
as something like in a legal sense that
they have to say that because they've
got bbc's got their solicitors etc but
looking at the track record of bbc i
don't think we have any room to assume
the best i mean if you have somebody who
is cons consistently attacking islam and
vilifying islam i think we can't really
say oh let's assume the best we're not
going to assume the best we're going to
assume the worst it's as simple as that
we're gonna assume the worst so to me i
don't think it's an issue of legal
now russell howard if you can think if
you think about it he has good
intentions in that sense where he's
trying to negate um
islam from isis yeah now we do the same
as well but let's be honest here we do
agree
that
isis is
muslims they are muslims i don't go to
the extremes of doing fear and seeing
they're not muslims they are muslims but
they are bad they are bad muslims so
russell obviously doesn't know the
technicalities in the religion of you
know doing fear or not but the point is
this he's coming from a place of
goodness where he does not want that to
be associated to muslims because he
realizes the consequences of media and
propaganda that it comes at the cost of
people literally wanting to take the
lives of muslims that we saw in new
zealand in christchurch so but when you
look at bbc you can clearly see the
issue is not legal yeah like he said
which was quite funny as well what's
isis is going to do write a letter to
you and say how dare you misrepresent us
you know we are we are muslims you know
so i did not understand the issue but
what really made it um to me uh can
really clear that bbc
has an agenda
like it's unbelievable that they are
picking on something so pathetic that
russell howard prefers not to even work
there why because he said isis are
terrorists they are not muslims oh no no
you can't say that say they are muslims
but you can say they are they are bad
muslims or whatever it may be the point
is this brother sisters it's this agenda
that's been pushed forward
all the time once again and what that
does brothers and sisters to us as
muslims is that this propaganda that's
been um continuously targeted at muslims
is coming from the higher up to the
lower down so you can clearly see there
that bbc are specific solicitors that
are bloody telling telling the
presenters or the comedians you make
jokes man oh don't say this but say that
who cares why are you so concerned
what's up daddy going to do um send a
defamation
what's he going to do so i just wanted
to share that with you guys to show that
russell howard that we salute him at
least he's coming from a place of
goodness and like allah says
allah does not forbid you from being
just and kind to those who do not fight
you based on your faith and kick you out
of your houses it is very very clear and
i just want to share that with you guys
brother and sister inshallah we ask
allah to guide him as well because he
does seem like a lovely child you know
at the end of the day um and yeah so
until next time assalamualaikum
goodbye